what's mental preparation look like like
how many years before the olympics
do you start helping an athlete believe
that they can win
an olympic medal
well i think it's got to be a seed in
that athlete's brain something they want
to do right
nobody
nobody can quickly get there right it's
a long process but if your goal if
you're a national champion or you've
proven yourself to win it in some
international tournaments and you think
the olympics is a possibility for you
then defining it as hey i want to be on
the olympic team
that would be the first step into
you know into um getting ready and
you know but you i always make them put
it on paper you know if it really is
your goal then you show me that it's
your goal and put it on paper and commit
to it i want to be olympic medalist i
want to be olympic champion i want to go
to the olympics world team member maybe
junior world team member whatever it is
we we walk before we go to the highest
level but
if the goal is to go to the olympics
let's let's accomplish these other
things first right because if we if we
can accomplish these other things
then we're on our way to getting to the
ultimate goal which is the olympics for
somebody like kayla for example you know
she didn't
say that she wanted to be olympic
champion you know when she first came
here in 2005 right
we wanted to become national champion
then we wanted to be on the world team
then we wanted to be a world medalist
then we our sites were set on the
olympics or the olympic gold you know so
it's it's having those clearly defined
goals that are attainable like they
should be a reach they should be a
stretch
but they have to be attainable they
can't be just a pipe dream you know but
once you put it to paper
and if you think it's achievable then
it's it's mapping the plan to get there
is there a daily process of visualizing
yourself as an olympic champion or
national champion yes
it is
you should do it every either every
night before you go to bed
or every
um before every training session or
after every training session one of
those three times it should or first
thing you wake up in the morning
because it may be to help some people it
motivates them to go do what it is they
they're supposed to do in the day
um
but the process of visualization is is
to me
is closing your eyes for
a few moments your brain works really
really fast right and it's actually
picturing the day
in its entirety from start to finish you
know from the moment you wake up and you
step on the scale
so the moment you have your breakfast
and you go through your morning routine
like live the day that you're going to
have at the olympics so whatever it is
you're trying to do let's say the
olympic day for example
picture yourself making weight picture
yourself who you're around eating your
breakfast you know having maybe saying a
few jokes laughing this is a real day
make it real yeah um going back and
getting packing your judo bag for the
day you know getting on the bus
driving to the venue feel what it's like
walking into the stadium
you know for the first time going to the
warm-up area
seeing your drawer up on the you know on
the sheet of who you're going to fight
that day
watching yourself warm up go through
your warm-up routine um walking out of
the chute you know into the venue going
to do that first fight picture the
moment of throwing your opponent coming
off the mat high-fiving the coach
getting ready for your second fight like
live the day from start to finish and
make it as real as possible
you know where all the way to the moment
where you've just won and you're raising
your arms in celebration you're bowing
you're hugging your opponent you come
off the mat you hug your coach
you're running around the stadium with
the flag
you know you you stepped up on the
podium you heard your name olympic
champion jimmy pedro like you heard the
moment
the the the metal being put around your
neck picture the people coming up on the
podium with you
arms around them taking the pictures
like
the more real you can make it
even before it ever happens
right
when you do that enough times
i feel that like
pathways get created for you so that
when your your body gets to that moment
and i've been here before this is it
this is my moment this is what i've
pictured my whole life i'm not nervous
because i've seen this this is going to
happen i believe it's possible right and
i believe the athletes that do that and
make it real enough
that when they get to that moment
they go right through there's no
hesitation
yeah this is what this is meant to be
this is my destiny this is why i did
everything i did
versus the ones that don't think about
it ever but just kind of like hope yeah
it's not real to them it doesn't feel
attainable they don't believe it's
possible they haven't committed to
believing it was possible without that
commitment in yourself and that belief
it can't happen and one thing that uh i
talked to travis a bit about this
uh you probably worked with him
on the details of what you're talking
about
but he said that you should really
like focus on visualizing like the
sensations
you feel so like say if you're drinking
coffee or something like that you're not
thinking about like
like observing yourself from a third
person perspective drinking coffee like
you're you're thinking of how your
hand will feel when it touches something
warm like you tried to replay the actual
sensations you would feel right so it
sounds
uh kind of strange but meaning like you
really want to put yourself in the body
as you would experience those moments as
opposed to like watching yourself on tv
experience in those moments like really
be inside and yeah so that means
sensations like how does it feel when
you grip a ghee how does it you know
um the yeah the the sweating just the
sensation of sweat
like rolling down your forehead or
whatever like all of those actual
feelings
when i explain it to you yeah like i
guess my body has been through through
it so many times both in my mind and in
reality that it brings back all of those
same emotions it
i start to get goosebumps my my armpits
start to sweat like i'm living it if
it's real yeah i'm reliving it now but i
in your when you're going through the
visualization process
it has to be that real the smells the
the the taping of the fingers like the
more colorful and the more real you can
make it
the more believable it is
you